and today we're going to be announcing
the current winners of the ctf yeah
so we've got uh should we wait a little
bit yeah we can wait a little bit
but is there
no one's got third place yet right yeah
i can say that so if you're uh still
working on the ctf
keep trying and you might uh
get the third place prize yeah we even
upgraded the second place prize so you
never know yeah merch can turn in
something really cool
yeah we got some cool stuff coming
uh any general updates you can think of
around open pilot or anything what
you're working on
well we're pushing uh 0810 hopefully
this friday
we got some good stuff in there um
it's a pretty big release
um just happened to be that way but we
also got some really cool stuff clapper
0811
um
yeah new sounds we're gonna go test
those after the stream our sound guy's
been killing it
yeah we don't want to give away the
the sounds just yet but yeah they're
they're they're pretty cool i can
preview the sounds yeah i guess we
should get my phone
their work in progress
we'll say that
yeah do you have one on your on your
phone yeah i got the sounds new open
pilot sounds and uh you know the
amplifier config on the three is going
to sound really nice so
yeah and a big
upgrade there
we'll do uh
oh you all play the liquidy one oh yeah
yeah
throw him out it sounded real abstract
at first yes
i think that was option d
let's turn the volume all right take a
listen
here we go
all right
what does everyone think of that
that was that was disengaged
here's engage
so
we didn't go with these sounds yeah
these are some of the options we're
saying the options
um what else we got
which ones did we like was that a f i
don't know
yeah we'll play f
just showing we're working on it
yeah
they sound real video gamey uh a little
a little complex
um but we got some stuff that we like
now um
really refining them um yeah it's for
both right yeah two and comma three yes
i think i don't think we've played them
on this comma two but if they sound good
on the comments too we'll we'll bring
them to the comment too that's the plan
yeah
so that's exciting
yeah this this release uh is gonna have
the first model trained on one million
uh segments so one million minutes which
is huge from research
and it's going to have wide why box the
black box driver monitoring which is
really nice someone just said in discord
today they're like i don't get it i have
a comma three but i can't see my face
off to the side now it'll see it like
way off to the side it's really great
yeah it shouldn't matter where you mount
it now that really shouldn't be a
consideration um while you're mounting
yeah it should just be
a pretty big improvement for a dm we're
gonna do a release blog post with this
really so i think you guys got a lot of
cool details you don't get it um
and the release notes we put on your
device
yeah yeah the blog is
is big now you know we're doing a lot of
blog posts and uh a lot more content you
can tell
yeah what's up
all right we want to announce uh should
we start
yeah well
what should we do first the first place
in the second place
they're both kind of first place now
yeah they're kind of both first place
all right what does this guy say
i get a random crackle you sometimes get
when engaging or disengaging is that
because of cpu affinity settings
no
is that just the amplifier config do you
know what that is are you talking about
the comma two or three i think it's like
on both wouldn't you
disengage
like
crackles are we gonna fix that with the
new sounds the new sounds also don't
have this problem we tested it pretty
extensively the new they sound great
they sound like real sounds
so it should be
fixed
oh thank you
yeah the new sounds they sound like real
sounds yeah um
we we ran out driving uh playing the new
sounds and then we went back to the old
sounds for fun and
yeah it was it was horrible we know the
sounds are not that great regardless of
whether you're coming to a common three
user um
so like we've been upgrading the ui um
with some like real design and stuff
let's get a couple of the sounds now in
the next release hopefully
it's been a work in progress um since
common commentary development to get
those new sounds out yes so they'll be
coming out soon um so the ui updates
should hopefully come out soon as well
uh we're talking to some designers now
um
yeah stuff's rolling all right yeah so
that's really wrong so are we just going
to jump to the chase and announce the
person who won first i guess yeah okay
all right so i believe on friday
um
david cook won first place um he found
all eight flags that was the first
mission with all eight um shout out to
gregor though um he's a former intern so
you know he wasn't uh really eligible
for the prize anyway but um he found
seven in i believe two hours like two
hours yeah that's impressive that was
pretty fast um
but uh divergent dave uh his username of
our first place winner
he found all eight um pretty quickly um
he found them all by friday i believe
right yeah i think so sometime sometime
later into friday i think yes and we
have one more participant who found all
eight he actually found ten of eight
flags um what was pretty good wait give
the what does that mean i thought they
were only so
um
we changed the
the route name to the date that we
released the ctf rather than
the source route that was used
and uh
it was harold
harold do you want to join yeah
y'all say hi to the stream
wanna come sit on the comma couch i've
got nothing nothing really to say
anything you want to tell the people
about zero
uh 010 is going to be very exciting lena
small is significantly improved
um dm mall's gonna be much better for
comma three it's gonna have a wider view
so
you shouldn't have the issue where even
though it sees you you're not in the uh
driver mooring model box
what else is exciting about we've got
acados which is just a
massive coat cleanup and some
longitudinal improvements
you might not notice that that much
though
it's great behind the scenes behind the
scenes yeah behind it under the cover
everything's great yes
cool well we were just talking about how
someone found 10 flags what oh yeah
crazy how did the flags how did that
happen that we didn't even know we're
there
um so the way that happened was um
there's this
the ctf route is a it's a fake route
right so we took a real drive and
injected the flags inside that route so
we found a route that we uploaded
before the final ctf one that was like a
work in progress one and we found some
other challenges that we were working on
there and some of the
the current challenges that were not in
a final state so we found two extra
flags that's crazy so although he's
second place um since our first place
winner um
indicated he wasn't interested in coming
we want to offer um
our second place winner
the uh travel accommodations so the
flights and uh at hotel to come out to
the hackathon
we thought that was a cool prize and
yeah we thought that should go to
someone who's attending
yeah so hit us up email us uh
we'll email you all right i guess we'll
yeah
you have to stream we'll email you after
the stream yeah um but third place is
still out there and you never know
what's third place right now it's what
was it merch yeah we have a lot of
people seven so you know competition a
little tight for that one yeah um just
gotta find one more everybody yeah just
just one more
it's gonna be easy
yeah
yeah so what the first place winner won
250 250 dollars right yes he won't do it
for three dollars since he didn't uh
he didn't want to come to the hackathon
yes unfortunately but uh our second
place winner he got 10 out of eight so
yeah
you know we've got we've got we'll say
those tied for first place but uh he's
in second place so he can either have
his second place hundred dollar prize or
the accommodations come out of the
hackathon i would have i'd pick that
personally if i could
nice what does this guy say
our flight is going to be revealed after
no so i think the ctf is going to we're
going to keep it around um as like a
form of documentation for open pilot
like if you
um if you're able to find the flags in
the ctf you should be pretty familiar
with open pilot infrastructure and some
of the tools we use
at least that's what we think let us
know if uh
if it was a good intro for open pilot um
do you want to show them the the new uh
testing closet let's clean it up it's
not ready yet okay it's a secret my desk
looks really nice
your desk yeah like the one sign up
isn't that nice
to center it look at that yeah
looks really professional yeah we got
real uh
comma threes uh production comma threes
in the testing closet yes so that's cool
with like you know real cases not 3d
printed cases yeah big upgrade
have anyone even seen like a 3d printed
comb of three games should we show them
we have one yeah
i mean we worked on the case for so long
yeah look yeah
look at that what a nice three oh let's
take this tape off
this is what the f-pot members will
remember getting
uh let's just say the injection molded
case looks a lot nicer
um people asking how many people are
going to be at the hackathon it's going
to be like rolling admission and uh
well we've got a lot
so far though yeah but uh
i don't know ideally we get everybody
who comes has eight flags but we'll see
uh yeah
so rolling admissions means basically by
the deadline everybody has an equal shot
otherwise uh as it gets closer to the
event the bar for admission becomes
higher and higher yeah so you know
there's only what two days left there's
only two days left for the you know the
first deadline but yeah if you wanna
come you can always play the ctf um
and put a good github in there i mean it
should be yours but you know make it a
good github
don't attach your resume please oh yeah
someone put his resume for the flags you
know the link didn't even work
oh man yeah so don't do that put actual
flags yeah but actual flags
that was really good
there's a band it's a van it sounds like
a bit i missed that one um but yeah
good stuff yeah i think that's that's
the ctf the ctf we got what have we got
like 30 submissions as of now yeah um
which is a little more than some of us
in the office were expecting but uh i
think we could still get more um
got quite a few more submissions
hopefully and before the deadline
um
yeah
keep going get eight um but it seems
like anybody who's found one flag um has
generally found at least four
so
once it might be a little hard to get
set up with open pilot we're still
working on that part um we're talking
about ways to make it easier today
but once you get in there you should be
able to find quite a few flags you
should be able to learn quite a bit
about a pilot and uh i think it's worth
it so
yeah someone has five so far
nice oh and if you guys have five and
you haven't submitted so far if you have
any amount of flags and you haven't
submitted so far feel free to fill out
the form anyway because you can always
go back and update it it's just cool for
us to know uh like i like seeing that
number go up throughout the day i
refresh that quite a bit so yeah yeah
then you're entered even if you don't
get all of them you still have a very
good chance of getting an invite to
comma hack yes you don't have to get all
eight i mean try your best you know but
we have to work on it's been a busy
couple weeks someone said they wish they
had more time to do both
i mean yeah it's rolling submission so
you can you can keep working on it um
but i mean as soon as you find the first
flag just
um submit the form and as you find more
you can update the form
um
we got some good ideas for part two of
the ctf we've been talking
yeah so i'm glad everyone's been
enjoying that and yeah the video contest
does end this friday uh we'll we'll see
how we're doing mid-week if you know
there's still no oh my god he's alive
yeah what did you think of the ctf
i think it's cool i tried to make it
work on mac and it didn't work on mac
the ctf is great i'm so glad that you
guys are out there using open pilot
tooling yeah
yeah that's great saying that someone
got 10 flags
10
10 of eight 10 of eight i i heard i
heard there were extra flags in the
hidden route yeah pretty uh pretty
incredible did we announce the prizes we
tell them what they're getting all right
great we got we got first and first star
yeah
we said second we didn't call it first
star oh i call it first star you know i
think we should yeah i think we should
uh
yeah
good stuff um are you gonna be around
when we do the video contest judging on
friday
uh yeah probably so we might yeah we're
gonna be doing that friday after lunch
like 1 p.m
and check out some videos so y'all have
a chance to make some good videos so
good luck
make them as good as you can yeah good
luck on the video contest get your ctf
submissions in
um by wednesday yeah uh yo
guys you know what i was just talking
about or just we're just the hardware
division you know commas not stopping at
cars right
like we're an ai agent company we build
ai agents
the the comma three is a head it has two
eyes it has a mouth it has two ears
just just just like your car harness
connects your comet 3 to your car and
the car is the body what do you guys
think of a mop harness
all right connects your comet 3 to a mop
and what if the mop harness is generic
and it also works with brooms
and it also works with
dishes
they have nice abstractions like cars
um
they don't well yeah i mean no the
obstacles are surprisingly nice you know
they're all the same well no but like
yeah what i'm talking about is maybe the
harness would have to be mechanical not
just electrical right like you could
imagine the mechanical car harness too
that would turn the wheel and would uh
you know uh press the pedals
mechanically yeah right so the mop i
mean i don't think many mops are digital
but what is the mop harness well the mop
interface is like you use a hand and you
pick it up and you move it right so it
sounds like we have to build a hand and
a way to pick things up
yeah we build little boxes for ais yeah
autonomous swiffer well yeah i mean it's
not like you know the the common body is
not gonna like
uh you know you're gonna just stick a
comma three on there
yeah it's the same head
lawn mowing is a good one so i just said
lawn mower ah
yeah it uses your push mower like in
stacy's mop video
yeah uh yeah
this is uh
so what we're thinking about your
comment for your actual comma three
will be able to you know who would buy
the common body
yeah right who wouldn't buy the common
body yeah
i'd buy it
how much is the common body
ah the secret
no no you know what we were talking
about guys you know what you're talking
about we're talking about how the comma
3 is expensive we know we know yeah
no one's happy about this right
like
the comment three despite it being the
price that it is we make less money
uh proportionally the the profit margins
are proportionately lower on the common
three than the comatose
so we made we made more more of your
dollars used to purchase comma twos of
profit than the dollars used to purchase
common threes which is just an
unfortunate fact
um but you know we're working on we're
working on tightening things up we're
working on lowering production costs
uh
but
that'll just raise our margins
uh
if you
sort something that folds close you have
solved ai you see the thing is you've
always solved ai if you build something
that plays chess you've solved the ai go
come on that's gotta be ai man
self-driving cars it's gotta be ai the
truth is it's no it's never ai
uh the girlfriend is maybe the hardest
thing to build i i mean that like when
you build something that can do
everything you know a girlfriend can do
then then then uh you know maybe they
need to all day i
yeah
uh
how many common threes have been sold
600 something yeah we got 669
i think a leak in live stream anyway so
no we don't know do we have secrets
anymore no secrets i mean there's not
there's something yeah there's not
really secrets anymore like failed
commentaries right there that we're
looking into
yeah they just have numbers on as long
as they don't have names
for information
yeah so we have we have one we have five
failed comma threes out of seven
fixes in the new agnos going out and
zero um
you know the common three does seem
quite a bit more reliable than the comma
two
um you know the the overall failure rate
of the comma two seems to be about
fifteen percent
uh maybe a little higher uh which you
know it's not great but
for retro for for perspective at in 2006
the uh
the wii the ps3 and the xbox 360
launched um the xbox 360 had failure
rates of almost 50 percent
uh so this is not unprecedented in
consumer electronics the ps3 was about
15. so we're similar to the ps3 uh we're
not as good as the wii you know not
everybody can be nintendo
but the common three does look better
um
uh we're not going to do the warranty
from one to two years and it that's not
really about reliability but the problem
with that is it would then require us to
uh
uh like like the logistics required to
plan that and the stock we would have to
keep right um we're not you guys know
we've raised 8.1 million dollars we've
made about 10 million in revenue
like we don't have uh you know a huge
warehouse where we can keep a million
dollars in inventory
uh required to to to be able to honor
that warranty right like we have a lot
of comments now that are just warranty
replacement commenters and this is all a
strict liability to the company so uh no
but the reliability is better
um
and you know we are very good about the
one year warranty
yeah that's very true
cool
tesla model three harness one
i think robert's working everybody's
working on tesla
yeah one of the issues with tesla is um
it's hard to mimic open pilots lateral
policy because tesla does this very
different like the wheel is locked until
you move it kind of thing the the like
cooperative steering that's in every
other car with open pilot is hard to
bring to the tesla
yeah
cool
yeah you flip one flag you can use your
tesla model s i believe you support ap
one or eight two model s's yeah yeah
yeah we should we should be able to
support them you know it was just in the
video i saw how many comments were like
like fsd shields oh these guys are way
behind tesla no we're one to two years
behind tesla like i tell you this all
the time right like it's like ios and
android and eventually we'll get to the
point where you know that gap kind of
collapses once you're that gap may have
already collapsed for actually providing
like the majority of the value
um the majority of the value provided
comes from
uh a chill highway experience
right and like
you you're you're
you're better off getting a
you would prefer as a consumer whether
you know this or not and sorry i'm
making a statement for you you would
rather something that instead of making
a mistake every hour on the highway
makes mistakes every 10 hours on the
highway versus something that makes
mistakes every hour on a highway but
also makes 90 degree turns
right you'd rather the former than the
latter you may not know that but it's
true
i mean it shows in the data too yeah
um you mean the engagement time yeah
yeah yeah um we have significantly
higher engagement times than tesla how
often a lot of people drive tesla
without autopilot engaged um people with
open pilot have open pilot engaged
almost twice as much
uh auto pilots engage like 30 of the
time we should adjust
our our statistics too right there's a
lot of engageability time that we can't
get back like some of the toyotas have
and the chrysler's you can only engage
in about 35 miles an hour yeah this time
is super high for everyone
yeah yeah yeah no we i mean we it's we
should actually plot the whole
distribution i'm sure this is true with
autopilot there's some people who are
using it like 98 of the time or
something but you know because well it's
much more cooperative um
you know it's it's easier to stay
engaged
uh
so yeah your comment three will just
you'll go use that expansion port you'll
plug it right into the comma body uh
comma body will go in the top port where
you connect the car harness right now
that's the thing harness port uh we'll
make the body speak obdc it'll use an
arm will be on can and stuff right use
cam for all that and then you always
have that other you know you've got that
other expansion port on the comma three
uh which as we sell more comma threes as
we start getting more data we can start
to train really large models even if the
models can't run on the comma 3 well you
can comma compute you know plug in the
compute
uh 30 90 in a box
uh and that should be enough to solve
self-driving cars right because what do
you need you probably need does the the
goal with the comma 3 was to be sensor
complete uh not necessarily compute
complete it may be compute complete we
don't really know but maybe not
but the usb 3 port on the comma 3 has
enough bandwidth to stream out the
entire sensorium of the dice so we can
stream that sensorium over the computer
with a 30 90
a 30 90 i would say a 30 90 can uh can
do level five
maybe four thirty nineties right can a
mouse driver copies the question that
439 is about a mouse
cool
yeah at the hackathon you can make a
cool project with that expansion board
too and you can set up your computer
your comma 3 is a computer you plug in a
monitor with displayport a mouse and
keyboard did we say we're doing a
hackathon with the office doing outside
no we didn't oh we decided that yeah
yeah uh oh oh yeah yeah you can the
commentary is a computer yeah yeah you
can sit at a desk plug it in you should
be able to develop open pilot on your
comma three did we get that to work in
west them no no that's that's their
project
[Laughter]
we released all the agnost stuff right
uh not wester but oh
why i don't think we can
oh
that's a shame yeah magnus builder
itself is open source yeah no i mean
look it's not like it's a secret like we
can talk about this no no sure um yeah
why because it's using down account
sources yeah
can we just like build less than what we
need special over there so what's in
there i mean it's just gonna be a lot of
work
if you guys want to come and rebuild
western upstream western upstream
western
upstream
did we fix that bug yet
which bug dui crash blog
oh it's just rare enough oh no
just right now
yeah that's extremely yeah well they
know what 10 hertz ui we're going to fix
down here 2i in the next release yeah i
don't think they're really interesting
oh it's not an issue in last release
okay okay great
pay attention to the road yet you guys
like that like the sounds
uh i hear really good things about the
new driver monitoring model
we played new sounds for them we showed
them a preview oh you showed them a
preview of your sounds you guys the
comet 3 has great has a great speaker
and a great amplifier it sounds like
[ __ ] now because nobody tuned it well
we're gonna fix it got a real guy to
tune in yeah we hired a sound guy
uh yeah no that was that was the tragedy
in humble series video when you hear the
comment three
screechy sound
i didn't even fix it we're fixing it uh
i don't think sounds are gonna make the
next release i'm going after i'm gonna
make next release we're gonna make the
next one oh oh great we're gonna try to
squeeze them into this one but we want
to make sure they're all oh you mean not
this one but okay yeah
um
uh you know antenna longitudinal stuff
is uh
it's coming along but it's just gonna
take time it's just gonna take you know
what we were fantasizing about in the
research meeting this morning we're
talking about the day when we're
training models on only comma three
datas for only comma threes nine months
nine months until the great deprecation
oh think of all the code we're going to
delete oh the great deprecation
comments will be left in a great state
though
yeah
yeah yeah no
right yeah yeah uh i mean the comment is
already kind of like
uh have we have we hit the thousand
hours yet for it we're really cool we're
really close to the thousand hours i'm
gonna come too i don't know
as well yeah our our goal our goal like
one of the goals for the common two
projects what we call open pilot 1.0 uh
is a thousand hours mean time between
failure on the comma two so we'll make
sure it's there
um i mean yeah what else is there like
the comma 2 is kind of a complete
product
yeah it is it is exactly what it is i
think all the the rough edges are kind
of polished
yeah uh and then you know onward to the
future with the comma 3.
um
and we'll see i mean we'll see how much
effort it is
i guess the open house will start to
diverge at some point yeah but it'd be
nice if like new cars could still well
like backboarded if it was easy enough
yeah
i mean
the way it's structured right now you
could probably even copy the self-drive
or the self-drive car directory that
should probably mostly work
yeah
yeah
cool
how's the accord someone asked oh i love
the accord that's nice do we have a
torque no we don't yeah but you still
love it i still love it the acc is
pretty good i want our acc to be like
that uh i know the honda bosch acc and
the handbag acc are very good yeah the
override is very comfortable in accord
too which are
the steering wheels the steering over it
yeah i don't know i haven't felt this in
the other cars either
i mean honda's on the honda's always
have the good swings changing see the
accord is great even without a torque
mod it's a little frustrating but you
know i drove to la and back and it was
still a great experience it had more
torque than i thought i'll be honest i
thought it was way less it was pretty
pretty decent uh
hg acc is good but too slow from a stop
like do you mean ours or do you mean
theirs they mean ours it's pretty slow
but there's a slow too it's just it's in
that's in the api apparently that's true
yeah the delay is isn't the delay is
apparently in the api yeah you know we
spent quite a bit of time on that i
think this is
the best we can do right now yeah well
you know the 10-day is still our small
pick for a level five car you guys ready
to see some 90 degree turns i changed my
position we love 90 degree turn
only on the common three though
no look
tesla a lot of people have fsd now
yeah i think they're they're releasing
to the 99 uh driving score we don't
score you guys you can uh engage with
openpipe one everyone we should start
scoring them i like that tesla we can't
check out our experimental branches
that's right that's true i like the
tesla does that you want stop lines you
know drive safely don't get driver
monitoring things
um pay attention uh
oblong say stop longer than hyundai we
gotta do better nibbles turn mode
what's nipples don't know what that is
uh look look we're a year and a half
behind tesla so in 18 months your comma
3 will make a 90 degree turn probably
right you saw the red lights and stop
sign demos we're working on them but you
know we do things right in a slow way
not hacky in a future way
uh like even when we talked about stop
lines this morning it's like well do we
really want to ship stop lines or do we
want to first focus on more into and
longitudinal stuff and the answer was
kind of ant and longitudinal stuff yeah
um
um
corolla 90. yeah i've seen the i've seen
the corolla already make 90 degree turns
oh yeah yeah yeah like seeing it you
know you people like people are like
hung up on this i should have said that
at comic-con like they just got hung up
on this like
like
my point is more like what do you even
mean by a 90 degree turn guys like well
we're gonna oh no no no we're like
hyundai we're gonna put a limit you know
the limit in the handbag yeah we're
bouncing back yeah that's right that's
right once you get the 89 open pilot's
just going to disengage all right that's
it we got to stop we gotta stop
somewhere we gotta stop somewhere
um
open pile is a 90 degree system yeah
what else you want it to stop you want
to make a turn all right let it stop
we'll have it make a turn you know dude
you want to tell me what your bonuses
oh we're driving a taco bell with uh no
disengagements yeah taco bell notice
engagements
how long has that been the the goal
last year last year nice
it's a long term goal yeah
cool i'm going to
love comma thank you
yeah thank you come body coming soon
uh commas all right yes comments already
360. oh they're going to need more
cameras where do you want me to put them
you know there aren't any more degrees
right
oh but they're not going to be able to
see through the back pillar yeah neither
can the human you know
yeah the comet 3 has plenty of field of
view for every part of driving except
for
cars approaching quickly on the side
which you need to know in order to make
a lane change but fortunately humans
struggle with this as well and that's
why we have blind spot monitors right so
good blind spot monitors plus a comma
three should be sensor complete to drive
a car right remember you don't have to
see every single bit of the road at
every minute humans don't do this either
you just need to be able to have a
holistic 360 degree understanding of
your place in space right and the comma
three can do this you know more than
well enough
oh man i don't know oh does the prices
only go up department have any incoming
announcements
nah now we're
the price is chilling for a bit the
price is chilling for a bit we
they're in the price justification mode
didn't that's that's how we renamed it
yeah the price justification department
um yeah we're
you're gonna be happy you bought a
comment three by the end like are you
happy about a comma two did it provide
enough value to you
uh
humans see a lot more of you inside
mirrors yeah questionable i mean that's
why you need the blind spot radars
but you can drive a car with outside
members take them off actually you can
it's illegal
george said i could take off the sidebar
you know
uh
will there ever be a need for the model
to remember more than two frames at a
time yes but you do understand we've
been doing this since it's open piled
0.6 right the model has infinite it's
it's an iir filter
it looks back infinitely far
it incorporates state from as far back
as you want well at train time we train
up to 30 seconds back so that's like a
practical bound
all right if we're up to if we're up to
those questions and i think uh i should
just remind everybody i want to be a
winner you got third prize is still up
for grabs yeah 100 bucks nope
merch right merch merch merch yeah yeah
there's some cool merch so do we have
hackathon
yeah we're gonna have a cool hack at
that merch it's gonna be great
and
you can come in a coma hack so yeah
already that's a great prize it's going
to be a really fun time
let your friends know about comma hack
see if they want to compete um reach the
kids let's reach the kids do you know
any kids
who want to go to college we try to
reach out to the local universities but
i don't know if they you know printed
out their flyer and put it on the wall
yet i don't think they did yeah we
didn't get any submissions if you do
nobody in the local universities
in san diego or l.a
let them know spread the word yeah
we want uh you know anyone who wants to
come work on cool stuff to come to the
hackathon yeah we're gonna have lots of
cool projects
um
and that could be you yeah
video contest probably ending friday
we'll see if there's no like crazy
submissions we can extend it but like
you know let me know on discord if
you're like hey i'm working on something
really great i just need more time
because otherwise i'll just not think
that anyone's doing anything cool
so
yeah
all right
bye everybody